[Music]
here in this video we will do a
breakdown and a bit of a review on the
new jurassic world dominion trailer that
was released yesterday
these dinos are back in town and here in
this upcoming flick there will be more
of them new ones that have never been
seen before and old ones that haven't
been seen since the first movie
we are all hyped up on this closure of
the jurassic franchise
and we hope it will be the best of the
best so remember to subscribe if you
haven't already and now let's get down
with this sickness
on the first scene we see a herd of
parasaurolophus being rounded up by owen
brady and a group of other people on
horseback kind of like a western flake
looking out for them bison and bees a
burden yeehaw it was a bit surprising to
see quite a number of them which means
that this movie will be set quite a few
years after fallen kingdom we then see
brady wrangling one of them up with a
rope and gently like aragorn speaking
elvish words into the broken rohan horse
he calms down the dinosaur and looks to
be forming kind of a born with it
next we see an apetosaurus in the snow
it seems like many of these dinosaurs
are up in the cold northern regions
maybe the northern part of the
continental us and canada by the looks
of it these sauropods are generally
believed to be
to live in tropical climates and migrate
south for winters to avoid the coal
but with these shots the jurassic
franchise wants to confirm to us all
that their dinosaurs are all
warm-blooded animals
that they don't really need the sun's
warmth to activate their metabolism
this would be one of the dinosaurs that
escaped from lockwood mansion in fallen
kingdom
then on the next scene we see something
that will surely make us say ah
and that is the scene of blue the raptor
with one baby raptor that looks like an
exact replica of her
the scene of them running around showing
that she is training her young one to be
an alpha predator and how to work as a
team raptors are back animals and young
ones grow at a fast pace and so they
need to learn how to run around and hunt
to survive in the wild
baby blue as i would like to call her
also has the same stripes as her parent
which means that baby blue might also be
capable of empathy as her parent
we then see owen brady
reunited with blue doing that hand
gesture trying to make her remember him
since they would have been apart for
quite a while since fallen kingdom owen
then talks to claire about blue being
safe in the remote forested region else
they would never be together again which
means that blue is on some sort of
reserve devoid of human population else
a human animal conflict would result in
a hunt for her and that wouldn't be safe
for her either for the baby we then jump
into the next clip and it's a mosasaurus
attacking a fishing vessel trying to
tuck away a fish catch from the boat we
hear them say in the background that
releasing the dinos from lockwood
mansion proved to be an ecological
disaster
and that the diners are wreaking havoc
on the food chain they become the alpha
predators and their place in the world
is chaos we then see the same clip of
the t-rex in the movie drive-in as in
the prologue the same one from the
prologue a few months back this proves
the same point that the dinosaurs don't
really have a place in the modern world
so the next set of clips shows us ellie
sadler and alan grant in a similar
backdrop from the first jurassic movie
it's the first time
they were seen together in the franchise
since jurassic park 3. we see the
dinosaur man in his excavation site with
which is kind of like a throwback from
the first movie where alan grant and
ellie are working together on digging up
fossils and they were recruited by john
hammond to visit his park full of
real-life dinos but here in the scene it
was ellie that calls gran for a mission
that needs his expertise which is kind
of probably how to tackle the
ever-growing concern of dino's roaming
america
now after that we switch on to a scene
of a group of parasaur loafers with
horses together in a herd running in an
open field which seems to be arid and
deserted with mountains on the
background next we see a newbie one that
was teased in a poster photo not too
long ago and this dinosaur is the
terrazinosaurus and even though this
creature is herbivorous it is
very clearly a very territorial animal
and will attack any intruders with a
super long claws
the protagonists were hiding from it
which means that they can't just run
away as it is probably faster and the
claws do have quite a reach
so we then jump to dr wu and dr malcolm
discussing the role of humanity and
nature and malcolm says that humans are
not above nature but instead subordinate
to it
this then switches to a group of
atrociraptors hunting claire and owen
grady on a bike
these raptors are very similar to
velociraptors in both size and hunting
style they work in a group of fast
runners and by the looks of it they are
more ferocious but why are they created
when velociraptors are already a
mainstay well maybe because
velociraptors are harder to control and
these atrocious raptors could be the
dinos that injin were looking for a
group of trained animals that follow
orders commands and hunts on order kinda
like how they wanted to use blue and the
others in the first jurassic world movie
as bioweapons and them as well as the
indiraptor in fallen kingdom but both
were failures in that regard
we then see grant and the others
approaching a hidden site which is
probably used for dino experiments and
breeding well after the destruction of
isla nubla and sauna by the volcano
eruption injen would have set up a new
site for such work and this might have
been it the place where all these new
dinosaurs came from we then see a new
feather raptor being unleashed one which
is slightly smaller than the others but
coated in red feathers and this is the
pyro raptor this is how a real raptor
would look like after all they are the
precursors of birds
we then see ellie and a group of
children running from what could be a
prehistoric species of locus
that could have broken loose from the
facility maybe maybe not maybe the
locusts were just part of a genetic
experiment gone wild or nature run amok
because of the presence of extinct life
forms
we again jump to the scene of atrocious
raptors chasing owen grady and they now
come across a couple of allosaurus
and the backdrop is kind of like a
spanish town with that yellowish orange
hue the sky probably mexico
i don't know haven't been there but
they always look like that mexico in the
movies dusty and orangey and yellowy i
guess they do have bright blue skies but
why don't they show it as that i don't
know
next we get to a scene where a group of
them are in an old airplane a propeller
driven one and they suddenly
suddenly a quetzalcoatl that huge ass
flying pterosaur from the dominion
prologue came
right on top and it came down attacking
the plane with pteranodons flying
alongside it as if they were a part of a
controlled group
then we see a herd of nasoceratops
attacking a convoy being very
territorial but what is strange as this
all looks kind of like plan or these
dinosaurs are in some sort of mind
control wrecking havoc and attacking
mindlessly
since they are usually peaceful
herbivores like most of the time
we then see a quick snap of baby blue
that small raptor caught in a trap and
blew the bigger raptor desperate to get
her child down from the trap a snare
this could very well be a chance for
owen brady to gain blue's truss or lose
it completely
since raptors can't climb trees we
expect brady to do that and cut down the
little baby blue from the snare and take
it to mama raptor thus earning blues
truss again and also her loyalty after
that scene we get a clip of maisie
lockwood
saved by a ladder from a big dino's
mouth about to clamp down on her as it
tries to jump down on the little girl
but by the looks of it we can guarantee
that this is a mouth
of a giganotosaurus
then very quickly we see ellie and
claire stuck in a control room in that
maybe secret dino breeding site probably
and they could be trying to shut down a
facility or stop it from doing these
unlawful activities
then next we see the dinosaur that
hasn't been seen since 1994 the jurassic
park and this is the dilophosaurus and
it looks good a bit bigger but good with
the frills and all that jazz this
dinosaur gave me the chills when i was a
kid and now it's kind of rekindling back
those memories
and now lastly after that we see the
group together shocked by the entrance
of a very big dinosaur and they said why
do they have to make them even bigger
which means that the giganotosaurus
emerging from the forest would probably
be the biggest meat eating dinosaur in
the franchise till date
maybe even bigger than the spinosaurus
or bigger than the indominus rex clearly
bigger than t-rex
and yeah that's it that's my take on the
trailer
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam